the founding father of gilead
he took away our country
he had to pay for what he did
one thing um that i wanted to talk to
you about first was pancakes yay i'm so
glad someone wants to talk about the
pancakes we'll talk about the pancakes
thank you nikki
what did that symbolically mean
like what did that moment mean for her
because she it's post-killing fred she
dives into them i could not love you
more for bringing up that scene thank
you very much uh we had a crew screening
last night and i was sitting next to
bruce and i leaned over to him and i was
like i think this is one of my favorite
scenes um what it means is it's a feast
it's it is uh warriors coming back
um
from the war
and feasting it's a bach and all it's
about i think also
seeing women
eat like that is so raw and interesting
and it's so it's so kind of visually
interesting and um all those women who
shot that scene were so fantastic and
they went to town and they ate and they
ate sausages and pancakes okay
they just went they were so committed
and i was so appreciative and i was
committed as well and and it was a
really uh but it's about them
enjoying the spoils of
their battle enjoying the victory
wow yeah a lot of pancakes were eaten
i'm sure and it was not a difficult task
it was brilliant to watch luckily i was
directing so i was able to do as minimal
takes as possible
i wanted to talk to you about directing
did you do one two and eight were those
the ones that you directed one two and
ten the finale oh and ten okay i haven't
seen ten they haven't shown it to me yet
let's not die haven't seen it wow
okay
you have such a unique like i know when
you've directed an episode
and bruce has said that you turn the
camera into an actor
and without spoilers the end of episode
two there is a
moment without spoilers can you talk
about directing a moment like that if
you can talk about it without spoilers
yeah yeah
i'll try
um
yeah i mean for me as an actor i've
always obviously used the camera as a
tool
it to me
it is my window to the audience it is
my
way of
communicating something to them
so i've loved as a director getting to
use the camera in different ways and
getting to use the camera to do that in
so many different ways um
we are able on this show to do very bold
things which i'm
very grateful for and what we do at the
end of episode two is very bold
um
you know and you know
yeah i'm like trying not to explain
anything but you know with the breaking
of the fourth wall kind of thing that's
a very bold thing to do on on television
and um luckily i'm given the freedom to
do that kind of thing and our actors are
game and our actors are so incredible
and they're so good and that particular
actor in that moment oh my god it gets
me every time
same same same same
it's just
she's phenomenal
and as a director
there's a shot and i've been asking
everybody in the cast this today there's
a shot of june that then is juxtaposed
with a shot of serena
you're wearing white she's wearing black
you're both looking in the mirror
and it made me think what do characters
on the show think when they look in the
mirror like metaphorically what do they
think now that june has killed fred has
her dna changed and how does she feel
when she looks at herself in the mirror
now who does she see
okay first of all nikki i very much
appreciate you it's very clear that you
have watched these episodes and been
very thoughtful about it and i
appreciate that thank you
um
i loved that scene and
and
it's them getting ready for battle in
their own ways it's the white swan and
the black swan that's why our beautiful
costume designer leslie kavanaugh put
her in black and me and white
um they're getting ready for battle i
think i think um a woman getting ready
is such an interesting thing to watch
uh
a woman looking in the mirror is such an
interesting thing to watch because
you're so it's such a vulnerable moment
and such a private moment and really
about the two of them
being in this vulnerable
private place
alone
just completely alone and yet
linked
inextricably linked
across time and space the decision i
know you and the two producers call
yourselves the triangle of trust
me and warren and bruce yes
was killing fred always the way like
what was that conversation like
and
how much do you miss joseph
ah
okay well first of all um
nothing is really always the way on our
show you know our writer's room and
bruce are very good at letting things
inform those episodes letting seasons
morph as we go along and they're very
it's incredibly collaborative
um and there's a lot of back and forth
so nothing is ever certain but i think
in the end
when we got to a certain place fred had
to go
you know what i mean he had to go there
has to be some justice
there has to be some justice on this
show and then to answer your second
question uh
desperately miss joseph
desperately he was such a wonderful
i mean he is such a lovely human
i mean so the opposite of fred you
wouldn't even believe it like just on a
family man and his beautiful wife and
beautiful children and like he's just
the loveliest man and um we all miss him
so much we would talk about it a lot
this season yeah i want to bring him
back i hope we can bring him back give
me this flashback straight come on you
know i was born is a cancer
we have to cut her out
there are consequences for disobeying
god
oh
blessed be this day one of the big
themes i think this season from what
i've watched is tables turning and when
somebody starts in one position they end
up in the polar opposite without
spoilers this happens a little bit
with janine this season
and her relationship particularly with
aunt lydia so can you without spoilers
can you sort of talk about your process
as an actress and that sort of shift
that dynamic
how fun was that for you to play
um
it was amazing i mean it was like it's a
totally different janine than than i've
ever
than i've ever done and i felt i feel
the same every season really every
season i'm like oh this is like a
totally different janine and getting to
explore new sides of her is always um
the most rewarding work but this season
with the kind of tables turning with
janine and aunt lydia i think we see a
side of janine
this season that is stepping more into a
i don't want to say the role of june but
more into the energy of june
um she's obviously been heavily
influenced by her friend june and um
that certainly makes tables turn a
little bit for aunt lydia um
and as an actor it's just it's just
marvelous you know to
try on a new um kind of attitude and
point of view for a character that
you've been with for so long that you
love so much and seeing them kind of
step into their power in a way it's like
seeing a really great friend like break
up with a terrible boyfriend or
something you know
it's like oh my god finally look at you
valuing yourself like it's like
it's really cool to uh to watch her
know she has power i think janine has
always known that she has the power but
to see her embrace it and to use it um
to try and help people
i'll help other handmaids it's really
wonderful your answer had me
now i have like 10 more questions to ask
you but i'm asking everybody today and
maybe it's a little more complicated
because of what you just said
what do you think the word or the
emotion is
or the core of who jeanine is whether
it's love or whether it's what is her at
her core what is the word that you would
use now that you've spent five seasons
with her
what drives her motivates her into
action
it is it is love
um but just more specifically than love
it's friendship i also like loyalty
janine is fiercely loyal i think she's a
taurus moon personally um
what does that mean
i mean i know what it means but what is
a taurus moon horace moo so that is how
you like handle your emotions your moon
okay okay you process your emotions for
example i have an aries moon so i'm just
like a raging [ __ ]
um
well i'm just kidding um but i think
that uh janine's like emotional heart
is
deeply loyal to the people that she
loves
i would describe her as loyal
what do you think janine's outside world
would be like outside gilead with her
newfound attitude what kind of life do
you think she could call for herself
that's a hard one it's really hard to
think about because
my immediate feeling is that i don't
want to believe that she is
too far gone
she's seen too much and too much has
happened like
especially throughout this last season
i'd like to think that janine just
wants
a simple life i think really
she wants friendship she wants to be
loved she wants to give and to receive
love i mean i don't think that janine
has ever wanted for anything
more than that
even before gilead and i don't think
that that has really changed i think
that's also something that we've seen
her seek throughout the seasons is that
she is looking for love
she's looking to give that love and to
receive that love
she's such a mother it's just like
she is one of those people that was
born to be a mom to give all of her
heart to something
there's a mirror
shot this season not involving your
character but it made me think who does
everybody's character see when they look
in the mirror and maybe it's more
metaphorical for janine but who does
janine see when she looks in the mirror
at herself
i don't think janine spends a lot of
time looking in mirrors
also because i think i mean the eye the
whole eye thing yeah
the whole other story yeah i think that
she uh
it always comes back to this for me she
sees her babies she just misses her
babies she sees i think you know when we
so much look like our parents like i
look at photos of if i just facetime my
mom yesterday i was like wow we look so
much alike
and i just like you see it you see it in
your yourself and in your children she
can't get to you so you just gotta
forget about her
so i finally got my wish this season i
have always been team luke and june and
we finally got to see that relationship
because we saw a glimpse of it at the
beginning of season one we find then
last season it was a lot of you know the
trauma and the re-entry this season we
really get to delve into the
relationship you have a meaty meaty
season i'm so happy for it and there
were so many brilliant moments i just
wanted you to talk as an actor how that
was for you
getting a chance and when i saw the
direction they took it in i was like of
course this is the way it had to go
oh thanks yeah luke i don't know we know
what it's the best bit about it to be
honest with me is getting to work with
lizzie moss like she is just so great
and you know i love working with all the
actors on the show but there is
something she's just so special to work
with especially when she's directing and
i don't know it's just like a discovery
we
there's a sense on set that we are
unpacking it and understanding it in
real time and you're gathering that on
camera and
i just love it and also like last season
he really very much walked on eggshells
with her because he wasn't sure it was
like and this season he says how he
feels and they get to the heart of it
they strip everything away
um
one thing i thought was really cool too
is that you sing this season
a spoiler on that
spoiler alert but you sing this season
are you always singing like offset and
they just
finally put it on camera or or not
really and and how did that sort of come
about that you were singing it's
beautiful
ah thanks well you know what i i i've
got another show on hulu called max mxxx
where i play a singer it's a comedy very
different type of show and i think i
think sometimes what happens it kind of
seeps into like writer's heads and
they're like and so so they put they
they put it in and um
yeah it it's it's a really
i i personally think it's really i
really like i don't want to spoil it
i think it's a really nice moment like
you say it's kind of connected with june
and luke and
yeah i think i i think they found a way
to put it in oh it was it was stunning
it was one of my favorite moments um
how does luke reconcile the fact that
june killed fred does it change it all
the way he sees her and is there
anything
he is such a family man he's done so
much to be there for her is there
anything in his mind do you think that
could actually tear them apart or have
him not fight for them as hard as he has
been
i think he's a stalwart um to be fair i
think you know he's so in love with june
and i think he has
he really just believes in his family
and believes in making that that work
but um
yeah i don't you know it's really it's
really hard because when these big
things happen like a war or you're
kicked out or people are killed your
whole sense of morality could change and
so of course like the idea of her
killing fred like you just killed
another human being that's a huge thing
on the other side it's her tormentor an
abuser and and so
he gets it
so do you think that anything could make
his love for her waiver ever or no
well i think it's not in him
where the season goes but i can
definitely say that
that that luke's love for
june and hannah and indeed nicole is
about as strong as any family man could
have this is why i love him so much i
love him
what is it about
june
do you think luke gets better than
anyone and what do you think he still
doesn't understand about her
if anything
luke still knows that playful
humorous
june that you know it's not humorous
but she's she's got a sense of humor to
her and and i think he
still sees it and tries to connect with
it i think
the revolutionary the the the
that's hard for him to reconcile with
right um you talked about how you love
it especially when she directs when
elizabeth directs and how you find
moments is there anything you can tell
me without spoilers a moment that you
two found together that sort of
surprised you unexpected you're most
proud of
um
there is one that comes to mind but it's
a big spoiler but i i would just
say that um
yeah um
near the end of this the show uh
everyone's gonna have their mind alone
serena doesn't know what
doesn't matter what she knows
it matters what she believes i'm calling
the two of you the dynamic duo i know
bradley that you use that line when
you're talking about serena and mark
this season but i truly think the two of
you are the dynamic duo you're starting
to dress up more alike you spend much
more time together you're starting you
know when people start to look like
their significant other or they're
starting to sort of morph
was that do you think that was like a
conscious thing on the part of like in
terms of like the look and sort of the
feel for me you know i just thought nick
needed a sort of uh addicted to love
[Laughter]
yeah we're definitely i i don't know if
it's or uh uh we can't stay away from
each other uh on set or off and i think
the writers just gave up and started
writing to it
i was i was thinking this morning brad i
was like
i saw that we're doing all our press
today together and i was like brad must
really regret becoming friends with me
because it's really legit
it's like he's really stuck in with me
um i it's a joy to work it's a joy to
work with him it's so fun i can't if you
told me
you know five years ago that i'd be
working in this capacity of an actor
admire so much i would have pinched
myself so it's a real it's a real
blessing and you're both wearing black
t-shirts today i noticed
you texted first well actually max is
in this bed over no
[Laughter]
if that had been the case it would have
been utterly brilliant um bradley your
one-liners i love commander lawrence's
one-liners i live for them i love that
the writers write this stuff for you my
favorite line of the entire season when
you say and you're referring to canadian
favorite sport hockey you say i love
hockey it's elegant
but brutal
is commander lawrence really describing
himself
in that statement i thought he was
playing with serena
uh i is is the maple i haven't seen it
is the maple leaf joke in there uh yeah
oh okay okay i i just want to say that
uh our um
uh liberal non-athletic uh wonderful
writing team
in in la
originally the line the line was um
looks like the leafs are going to do it
this year and i was like you guys and
i'm from wisconsin so i know a little
bit about hockey i'm like
they never win
they haven't they
so i think we changed the line to
something like they're gonna break
everyone's heart again and i was proud
of that writing change
and i i still do not understand how
toronto beautiful
massive
toronto uh in a country that is just
hockey matt has not managed to win a
stanley cup
since i was in first grade
well i am canadian i am from toronto and
i'm in toronto right now so i understand
even though i live in l.a
um
max yes
do you think that
nick and june could ever have a healthy
relationship
and does it change the way he sees her
because she killed fred um so to answer
your last question first no i don't
think it changes how he sees her um i
think he's sort of attracted to that
oh
i allow myself a certain naivety
you know what i mean a certain optimism
that may be misguided i have no idea i
hope so but
i i'm somebody who you know as a as a
watcher of the show and i'm not just
saying this to be diplomatic i'm
incredibly sort of drawn towards the
nick and uh sort of the lucan june
relationship too
and i
i don't know if i was to vote as an
audience member which way i'd want that
to play out or if she necessarily needs
either man in her life wow so this is
the person who plays nick i i am
advocating for him but um
i don't know what decision she'll make
and and i don't know what decision she
needs to make yeah well speaking of
which my very last question to both of
you is
who do you uh there's a there's a mirror
motif in the season it doesn't involve
your characters but it made me think who
does your chara who do you see who does
your characters see when they look in
the mirror
like what are they what do they think
about themselves who do they see
and for each of you as actors the end
game even though you don't know where
the writers are going do you want your
character to go out in a blaze of glory
like a death a fiery death or do you
want your character to have a happy
ending i want
lauren's to ride off into the sunset
you know you get some animals i think
that's what would make us happy just
some space and some animals so some
space and some animals yeah i'm just
laughing about like we joke a lot on the
set it happens a little bit with serena
this year about
um
the uh
uh bachelorette gilead edition
yeah
you may not get a rose but when you get
kicked off you get put on the wall i
think it's an interesting idea
an interesting idea for the show uh to
answer your question um
as a fan of the show
playing this character i have an idea of
when you say look in the mirror uh i i i
think that june is
blown on the spark of decency in both of
us um
at the same time
you know the last thing uh
this particular story needs is a male
hero
so i tussle with that i have a lot of
hopes
where
like
i want lawrence to go but i don't know
if that's going to be the direction it
goes or if he is capable of that or
should be nick doesn't seem like a guy
looks in the mirror a lot
um to me
doesn't you know in a metaphorical sense
or a literal sense i don't think that
he's somebody wants to do a huge amount
of
self-examination
yeah he just happens to look like this
no i don't think i don't i don't i don't
he does he doesn't strike me as like a
particularly like um
introspective person which is actually
kind of different to me who's completely
driven by ego and um self-involvement so
there's something actually kind of
liberating about playing somebody who's
much more straightforward
his journal entries are very
very straight that's fair he's like
hemingway
yeah cold today
my job is to protect you
tell me you can protect me from her the
first question i'm gonna ask is sort of
something that both of you can answer
i'm asking everybody in the cast today
now that you've spent so many seasons
living in your character's skin what do
you think the core emotion that drives
your character is like
is it love like think inside out those
those pure emotions that sort of
defines who they are
i'm actually thinking literally of the
inside out characters
and i'm like well i'm not sadness nor am
i joy i saw i have to
find something in between mark's a
mystery
yes
yeah mark whatever mark's emotions are
he has to guard them and i think it's
for the sake of you know this
country that what's left of this country
that he loved and trying to regain
democracy and all
all the wonderful things that you know
go along with that so
um whatever emotions mark has i think he
kind of uh doesn't let out until he gets
back to his apartment in toronto
yeah i want to know what he does at
night
i think he's pretty lonely
yeah i think he's got you know refugee
friends and you know but i think he
tried probably keeps to himself i think
i would say uh empathy
i think that uh
rita at the beginning when we first meet
her in season one is uh not the warmest
person that's because i think she has an
incredible amount of empathy
and feels everything so
uh tremendously
and as we
begin to peel away the layers we really
see her fight to forgive serena fight to
forgive fred even the way she sort of
dismisses fred is with empathy
and even coming to this season and she's
still empathetic with june wanting to uh
just um
go back and burn gilead to the ground
but she also wants to move forward so in
the she has an extremely tough exterior
but inside i think she's just
um
probably one of the most empathetic
characters sam i have a question for you
and i'm going to be hard-hitting with
this one why does he indulge serena why
does he keep indulging her do you ever
look at the page and go why why are you
doing this
i think this season i i think there's a
couple of times where mark has gotten
himself into
uh
in trouble just uh allowing serena to go
a inch a little closer towards you know
her her um
her need to control um
but uh you know i think mark is kind of
enamored with who serena was before
gilead and i think this
this season more than any other he's
realizing
just how far
she is from that um
and uh
you know these desperate times for
serena she's a survivor she's a a
warrior much like
much like june uh and
you know i think he realizes that she's
going to do whatever means necessary to
ensure her survival
and that's a very dangerous person to be
being close contact with for sure i told
you last season i think they look at
each other with love me eyes i don't
know what it is like the forbidden fruit
that he should never go after but does
he have romantic feelings that could
have ever
come into play had she maybe gone down a
different path
yeah i mean we may
see a little bit you know just glimpses
of that this season um
but uh it's
again it's such a dangerous relationship
i think they're attracted to
how calculating one another is and and
uh but yeah this this is uh there's a
clear line in the sand this season for
sure
um amanda you have a scene
um rita has a scene
with june in the kitchen and i'm not
spoiling anything by saying
that she says to june like i live with
trauma too even though i wasn't a
handmaid and it is such a beautiful
scene i love the way you played that
scene it was incredible
um can you talk about
the other thing i noticed about rita
she's still in the kitchen a lot she's
still
helping and
you know what i mean like so is that
part of the trauma that she hasn't been
able to escape do you think okay
absolutely i mean we do have a running
joke elizabeth is always looking for
banana bread as a prop for me to carry
whenever there is whenever we start a
scene
um but it's familiarity that was her
purpose her sole purpose for years under
um the most horrific circumstances and
in order to survive gilead she had to
really excel in the kitchen and so you
don't just shake it that easily this
year
last year we saw there was a bit of sort
of shell shock she just stayed there
because um it was really the only thing
she knew and this year i think her
relationship with the kitchen um is
she's beginning to find joy again
beginning to find purpose outside of
gilead but i i agree with you i'd love a
scene in a bathroom
like a living room there's some
not boiling but yeah yeah there's a lot
of kitchen stuff okay real quick um
who do you think your character
would at least want to go up against
and be on the bad side of june or serena
because serena there's a shot of her
doing yoga she's a very like understated
poised villain where june has rage who
would your character at least want to be
on the bad side of can i go see none of
the above
sure
these are
very headstrong women and so passionate
and fiery and uh you know it's what
what's it's what makes them such
fascinating doppelgangers in our series
is that
um man they just both hold so much
weight not just as you know characters
but the those two
actresses that uh amanda and i get to go
to work with they're just um they're
just amazing you know they're amazing
people to be around so
so i gotta say
i would say june
yeah
no
no thank you
no even the scene doing the scene in the
kitchen where i do have to push back
against her i was terrified no no and i
am a good foot taller than
than jun so but no no thank you i will
take serena any day
i pray for our children
may they live a life without all of this
hate
[Music]
dear god
may they do better than we did
season five to me
when i think of a theme i think table's
turning where somebody's station in life
began some way in season one and now in
season five and relationships take a
180. in terms of power dynamics the
character's station in life and then
visually you show it by juxtaposing two
scenes together like june wearing white
serena wearing black like somebody
taking a bath somebody being dirty i'm
wondering for
for you um
i know you have your triangle of trust
between the two of you and elizabeth
when you have these meetings how did
this sort of take place how it's how did
you decide that this is the way season
five would be shaped i i think it's a
combination of things it really does
start kind of with the writers in the in
the writers room talking in very big
ways about what we could do in the
season and big themes i mean i think
we're not afraid to talk and think about
themes
um but i i also think a lot of it
comes from
having initial rougher conversations
with warren and lizzie and then when
lizzie is not just
acting but also directing
you you have these preliminary
conversations but when you get to the
end of it you and you drink the whole
season it it's different and i think
that's what you want so what you're
trying to do is not say it's gonna mean
this what you're gonna which i think
what i'm always trying to do is warren
and me and lizzy and all of the writers
we have interesting conversations about
stuff that june is going through this
season put all of that together and then
when you see it when it's all together
look at it and say wow you know
you know water was a really big theme
this was the theme that was you know
turning tables you know taking each
other you know people on the top are
it's an expression from the civil war of
a a former released slave when he saw
his owner coming down the street said
oh he was talking about a fence rail he
said the bottom rail's on top now you're
not afraid to take big swings like you
said was there ever any hesitation to
have june kill fred
take her out of gilead and then location
location location you're very much on
location more than you ever have been or
is there ever hesitation between the
three of you was was elizabeth ever
reluctant to to perhaps have her
character kill fred
never i mean she she um first of all i
don't i don't
it would be wrong even though these guys
are my creative partners to float things
as possibilities to my main actor that's
just not cool because to say you might
do this and you might do that makes it
harder for her to make a realistic
person so
so i try not to i try to talk to lizzy
and talk to everybody and then you
really try to get it down in the scripts
and then when they get in the script
it's much more
solid i don't think we get to the point
where
lizzy or anybody would balk because
those conversations are ongoing and also
hopefully and this is something you know
war and i both do when you watch the
cuts
you see what they're doing and then you
go back and talk to them about do this
more do that more push in this direction
in that direction
we've been doing this long enough and i
think the most
effective part of our process is the
communication between the cast and the
writers and the producers that it's open
and comfortable and everybody's a grown
up and a professional and everybody just
wants to make a great show for
nikki and you do and you do
one thing i would say is um it's a
tribute to joe fines
that he lasted four years um there's
other actors who probably would have
said
let's get rid of them sooner and we
couldn't
we were we had our own addiction to fred
waterford and to joe and what he brought
to that and we stretched it as long as
we could but ultimately
that was we were waiting for that and
the audience celebrated it
so we go off this year with all right
june now deal with it
right
right yeah it isn't you know in tv the
tv goes off and you go back to your
stuff that the people in tv still have
their lives so june even if the show
ended she'd still have to deal with it
i'm interested
i know uh warren you've contributed you
you did cheers you did seinfeld those
are the shows that we need to watch
after we watch the handmaid's tale to go
to sleep
that's true
do you ever watch any of those your own
shows before you go to bed working on
this show let's face it um
not just the handmaid's tale the world
we live in is difficult
um so i i celebrate sports because i
have to pull myself away from news
i i have to get something else in there
where i can be
joyful um
but i i think
you know
we're doing it
i think a really compelling human drama
um that is
first and foremost about the battle for
feminist rights um and
that relevancy our audience keeps
standing up and saying
um we need it we want it um and yes we
also all need and want in our lives to
laugh and
i go back to those comedies as well yeah
my last question is for you bruce i know
that um handmaid's tale book has been
stewing in your brain since you're about
20 maybe even younger and that you have
said you have the end game in sight for
this for this the way the series is
going to end i'm a canadian i grew up
reading her book it was required reading
in school um does that change much i
mean i know the seasons probably
morph and shift like you talked about
earlier but does the end game ever
change in your brain obviously i don't
want to know what the end game is but
does that ever change for you is it ever
in question or in flaws
uh i think it
the end game does change um not in not
in
uh
kind of what's going to happen but the
manner in which things are going to
happen and i i the book is really i mean
you you read the book i read all you
want to know is what happens at the end
i mean in the end it kills you you know
when when i originally got the job
everybody was like how can you go on
from that book i'm like
what do you mean i mean i've wanted to
since i was 20. find out what happens
after the line she gets up in the van
it's over so i think that you know i i
was a big kind of fan of kind of moving
it
uh you know forward
so um i forgot your question again i
didn't write it does the end game change
oh does the end game change and and but
i think that
remarkably it stayed
very very close and i think that's
because of lizzie and i had talked about
it had had been having conversations
about where we want her character to end
very early on just i don't know what we
were hoping for maybe a big hit but uh
so i think that uh
we've been very much on the same page
and revisited it a ton over the years so
it's i'm sure it's changed a lot from
our first conversation but but it really
has remained kind of
the same set of circumstances and where
we want everybody to end up and you know
kind of the ways and the manners change
you